[Music]
this episode is brought to you by 4
Sigma Dec founded by the genius Finn's
who lit the internet on fire and you may
have heard of their mushroom coffee
which features chaga and lion's mane
which has taken Silicon Valley by storm
I use it pretty much every day either
that or the chugga which is decaf as a
separate version and I use both of these
primarily for focus and productivity
they just get you going let you up like
a Christmas tree so definitely check it
out people are always asking me what I
use for cognitive enhancement and for
right now this is the answer I try to
force this on all of my houseguests it
is a hell of a thing if I have employees
or people come over who are working on
projects with me I always try to feed it
to them because I'm going to get the
limitless effect it's a lot we're out of
them the first time I mentioned this
product and for sig Matic on the podcast
their products sold out in less than a
week so you may want to check them out
soon if you're listening to this and the
coffee tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you would get in a
regular cup of coffee I don't get any
jitters acid reflux or any stomach burn
any of that it's very unusual and very
very cool so if you don't like caffeine
they also offer very strong but caffeine
free mushroom elixirs which I will
sometimes have in the evening I find
chaga specifically to be very very
grounding and earthy so that is another
option and I have a cupboard full of
their products at the moment which is
right around the corner in my kitchen
you can try something you can try a
sample pack which is great also right
now by going to four sig Matic calm
forward slash Tim that's for sick
maduk fo you are SI GMA TI c comm
forward slash tim and use the code tim
TI m to get 20% off of your first order
and they're not that expensive anyway if
you are in the experimental mindset I do
not think you'll be disappointed to try
them this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens I get asked all the time
if you could only use one supplement
what would it be and my answer is
inevitably athletic greens it is your
all-in-one nutritional insurance I
recommended it in the 4-hour body did
not get paid for that and I travel with
it to avoid getting sick I take it in
the mornings to ensure optimal
performance it just covers all my bases
if I can't get what I need through whole
food meals throughout the rest of the
day as listeners of the Tim Ferriss show
you can receive 30% off of your first
order by visiting athletic greens comm
forward slash to him that is a great
deal on one of my favorite products and
it covers my basis each day it is part
of my routine and it leaves me with less
to worry about if for instance I have to
skip a meal or just can't get a
high-quality meal so check it out go to
athletic greens dot-com forward slash
Tim and learn all about it
hello my little munchkins boys and girls
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where it is always my job to deconstruct
world class performers to share the
thinking the habits the tips and tricks
that you can apply in your own life
whether those people come from the
worlds of sports from chess from
entertainment and in this case from
investing I'm very very excited about
this conversation you are about to hear
I had a blast it is with Ray Dalio who
has been called these Steve Jobs of
investing and we'll get to why that is
the case this is Ray's first long-form
podcast ever which I'm extremely happy
to debut here on Twitter at Ray Dalio
you can say hello grew up a middle-class
kid from a Long Island he started his
investment company Bridgewater
associates out of a two-bedroom
apartment at age 26 now has roughly 160
billion dollars in assets under
management over 42 years he built
Bridgewater into what fortune considers
the fifth most important private company
in the United States now along the way
he also became one of the 100 most
influential people in the world
according to time and one of the 100
wealthiest people in the world according
to Forbes and because his unique
investment principles have changed
Industries CIO magazine is the one who
dubbed him the Steve Jobs of investing
very important ray believes that his
success is the result of principles he's
learned codified and applied to his life
in business and certainly at Bridgewater
those principles are detailed in his new
book principles subtitle life and
business I highly highly recommend this
book it has already changed how I think
about making decisions in my life and in
my business how I think about managing
how I think about communications between
teams I could go on and on and on and it
features just check out the blurb from
Bill Gates on the cover
I'll give you an idea of the type of
people who listened to ray very very
closely in this interview we cover all
sorts of ground including
how ray thinks about investment
decisions how he thinks about a
correlation for instance and so on the
books he would give to every graduating
high school or college senior how he
might assess something like
cryptocurrencies walking through the
thought process and much much more we do
get into his backstory and how he became
an investor and so on if you want to
just jump right into a bunch of
nitty-gritty investing detail which does
get into the weeds then you can jump
about 90 minutes in but we do cover a
lot of really good stuff and many
principles that apply in the first 90 so
I suggest that you listen to the whole
thing but if you're super impatient and
you want to jump around you can jump
about 90 minutes ahead and check that
out so I hope you enjoy this as much as
I did and without further ado here is
Ray Dalio ray thanks for coming on the
show looking forward to it thank you for
having me I have been such a follower
and fan of your work in your writing and
my audience has been asking when I would
reach out to you to have you on the show
so this is this is a very exciting
moment for me and I would love to start
at the beginning because it seems like
we have some at least shared Geographic
beginnings where did you grow up and how
would you describe your childhood um I
grew up in New Hyde Park Long Island and
I would describe my childhood as being
middle-class or maybe a little bit lower
middle-class family my dad was a jazz
musician my mother was a stay-at-home
mom I was an only child
were there any formative experiences you
had say up until the end of college that
ended up informing your decision to
become involved with investing yeah when
I was a kid I used to caddy and at the
time the stock market was hot and when I
was 12 I got hooked on the markets
I bought a company that you know
everybody's talking about the markets
and
I decided I would take my catting money
and put it in the stock market and so I
picked the stock the only stock I knew
that was selling for less than five
dollars a share and it was kind of a
stupid idea but I thought if I'd bought
more shares in a wait up went up I'd
make more money the company was about to
go bankrupt and somebody came along and
acquired it and I tripled my money I was
lucky and I was hooked on the stock
market so that had a big effect that you
know so from then on it drove my whole
addiction to the game and everything
I've been doing since related to my
career SID I think that many people who
are listening to this who know your name
and your bio have the impression perhaps
that every time you've stepped up at bat
you've hit homeruns that it's just been
an unending streak of homeruns and I'd
like to maybe humanize the experiences
you've had a little bit by talking about
1982 and I'll I'll back into it by
reading just a short excerpt from your
book which I think paints a good picture
it begins with so there I was after
eight years in business with nothing to
show for it though I had been write much
more than I'd been wrong I was all the
way back to square one at one point I'd
lost so much money I couldn't afford to
pay the people who worked with me one by
one I had to let them go
we went down to two employees Coleman
and me then Coleman had to go with tears
from all his family packed up and
returned to Oklahoma and at that point
you were down to one employee that's you
and to make ends meet you had to borrow
$4,000 from your dad until you could
sell your second car how did that happen
could you describe what happened and
they brought you to that point let me
first say that by the way I'm a
professional mistake maker you know
being in the markets or being an
entrepreneur requires one to bet against
the consensus and when one does that a
fair amount of times you're going to be
wrong a fair amount of times and I've
learned a lot more from my mistake so I
just want to let you know that anybody
any perception that being right as part
of it
know that main thing is knowing what you
don't know and how to deal with it but
anyway what happened at the time is I
analyzed the payments that country's own
banks and I calculated that those
countries were not going to be able to
pay the u.s. back and it was a very
controversial view at the time and as a
result of that I took positions in the
markets and I got a lot of attention
because Mexico defaulted on its debt not
many people had expected that and and I
did and I had these positions on and I
thought the stock my thought we were
gonna go into a depression I thought the
stock market was gonna go through the
floor I just didn't understand really
and the stock market rose and this was
after I had testified to Congress and I
was on Wall Street week and then I had
lost the money that you referred to and
you know that that's how it happened and
in retrospect it really was the best
thing that ever happened to me because
it gave me the humility that I needed to
become more successful and that was
because you know I shifted my attitude
from thinking I'm right to asking myself
how do I know I'm right and that opened
my mind a lot it made me look for people
who disagreed with the smartest and it
also made me manage my risks better and
so on so that's the story I'd like to
dig into mistakes I think this will be a
common thread throughout the
conversation I have read and correct me
if I'm wrong but that you're a fan of
for instance the book Einsteins mistakes
subtitles yeah the human failings of
genius he was one of the greatest minds
of the 20th century made a lot of
mistakes you have a an expression which
is pain plus reflection equals progress
and my understanding is that at
Bridgewater you have for instance
lengthy assessment sessions in which
employees discuss their mistakes what
type of post mortem
did you do after all that happened in
1982 or did that come later the type of
post game analysis that you would do on
what led to that mistake I think for
everyone and for me at the time when you
encounter the mistake and you experience
in that pain and there's an emotional
pain and that was true for me at the
time and then the pain passes and it
requires thought and making the
connection of what did I do wrong and
being analytical about it and that was
that experience and and that led me to
do that as a habit it became an
increased habit I would literally every
time I would make a mistake I would
develop an instinct so it changed my
attitude about mistakes I think
basically they became like puzzles and
if I solve the puzzle the puzzle being
what would I do differently in the
future I would get a gem and that gym
would be a principle that would let me
do a better job the next time that sort
of thing came about and I wrote those
principles down and refined them over a
period of time which is what makes up my
book but it was that process of making
enough mistakes and having painful
mistakes that led to an instinctual
reaction to have reflections on what I
could have done differently that led to
the progress that I'm referring to when
I say paying plus reflection equals
progress and I think we all learn I
don't I don't think it's particularly
just true of me I mean I think anybody
who's open mind in it and smart knows
you're gonna learn more from mistakes
there's so much more that you can learn
from mistakes because I mean mistakes
well first of all they're giving you a
loud signal and rewards keep you doing
the same things and so you don't grow
from successes successes keep you doing
the same thing so you don't grow from
successes what mistakes
if you
deal with them the right way is where
the growth plus the reflection is where
the growth comes from so anyway that's
what happened could you give an example
from your life of a particular mistake
in how you did that analysis or
reflection after the fact
and what you learn from it well I mean I
they're just so many mistakes when I was
just getting out of college I clerked on
the floor of the New York Stock Exchange
and this is when the dollar was attached
to gold and it was a financial crisis
and Richard Nixon gets on the television
and says there's no more attachment to
gold
and back then money he was like checks
in a checkbook that didn't have much
value what really mattered was the fact
that you could get something tangible in
the form of gold that you can make the
conversion so it was a crisis our money
wouldn't be taken in other countries and
so on and I walked on the floor of the
New York Stock Exchange Express
expecting a collapse and the stock
market went through the roof it never
happened to me before so that was the
case and I went in researched currency
declines in the past and I learned that
it happened before but just not in my
lifetime and one of the things that I've
learned over the years is that many
surprises come because they know things
that happen as surprises never happened
in one's lifetime before so that it's
advantageous to look at beyond one's
lifetime or beyond one's own experiences
to understand how the world works so
that one can anticipate all of those
things and learn all the rules of how
the world works and that's the beauty of
it right and that's the excitement to
learn you know how does reality work
what are the cause-effect relationships
and then how do I deal with my realities
so that's a case but I mean there you
know there are so many mistakes
I would like to dig into the research of
history things that have happened
outside of your lifetime because I read
that for instance while on one hand you
have say Soros who might credit the
influence of Karl Popper who was one of
his teachers at one point you've talked
about diving very deeply into past
periods of economic upheaval right the
great depression or reading daily
newspapers from those eras are there
other practices or approaches that
you've taken to examine history are
there any particular types of books or
resources that you go into like that to
try to get a better picture of reality
before I deal with the particular
economic history all I'll start off by
saying I believe that basically
everything is another one of those in
other words almost everything happens
over and over and over again through
history and that the key to success is
to identify what one of those it is and
to look how it's worked in the past many
many many times and then to understand
the cause-effect relationships to
develop one's principles for dealing
with it so it could be applied to
anything we were talking about economics
to talk about politics nowadays we're
hearing the term populist and populism
is something that is a bigger phenomenon
that than we're used to in our lifetimes
the time that populism was flourished
the most was in the 1930s pretty much
leading up to World War two and so I use
that as an example I think okay where
were the populace in history where were
those cases how does this thing happen
what are the how does it grow how does
it develop what are the usual linkages
and why and so that's been I think very
helpful more recently and my
understanding quite a bit about what's
going on it's affected my perspective so
it doesn't have to be just reading
history books you know it's in anything
people have a new child and they treat
it as though that's the first time
anybody's had a child the pain
perspective you can apply it you know
gain that perspective of what's happened
over and over and it can be applied to
anything if you start thinking that way
it's radically beneficial so when it
that way when I'm referring to that is
in other words what is this what what
one of these is it and how do those
things work and what are my principles
for dealing with it then life is a whole
lot easier if you're not dealing with it
that way everything is a one-off and
you'll be in the middle of a blizzard of
things and you want to step above those
in and deal with those instinctual
principles for example you have your
principles I really admire your stoicism
and I think you could rattle those
principles off and you make the
connection and it's connected to your
realities so we each have our own I
don't want to keep it in the realm of
just economics because it applies to
everything definitely well I would love
to talk about problem-solving and I'm
sure principles will tie in here but
let's just say hypothetically and I'm
sure this is is maybe a real case at
Bridgewater over many many years but if
you have someone who's working at
Bridgewater very very smart very
ambitious and they've made a mistake and
they are in the they enter an assessment
session what does the format look like
and how do you help them separate
symptoms of problems from the root
causes and the actual problems I think
the first thing I have to convey is that
we have an idea of meritocracy so it's
not like somebody is called into a room
and the people like me or the bosses
think that they know the answer right
and that they're making an assessment of
how that person is and then they write
down those notes no no it's everybody's
equal and having an opinion and by and
large if the person
that's receiving they received great and
bad feedback and what an IRA fee
received great and bad feedback in a
night non-hierarchical way we approach
it with the idea of how do we find out
if it's true so it's got to be
evidence-based and then we will set up
tests let's say if you're if you get bad
feedback we're down talking about bad
feedback it could be for good feedback
but if you have if somebody's thinking
somebody's not very good at something
they're speaking honestly most
importantly it's that people can be
radically honest with each other and
they'll say I don't think you're very
good at that and they said I am very
good at that and then you go through a
series of tests to think it's
evidence-based to try to find out if
somebody's good at bad at that and then
you move beyond it to think okay well
what can I do to get better or how can I
guardrail myself so that if I'm weak at
something and somebody else is strong at
that thing we can work together the main
thing here is to get at what people are
like you know this is to me it's a weird
world that there's a phobia about making
mistakes and there's a phobia about
knowing one's weaknesses mistakes are
part of the process and everybody has
weaknesses the greatest people I know
have weaknesses and have become
successful because they know how to
compensate for the weaknesses they're
aware the stupidest people I know least
successful people I know are people who
don't own up to those weaknesses and
grow so the exercises that we're going
through or by people who choose to want
to be in a radically truthful or
radically transparent environment and be
evidence-based but it's difficult it's
difficult because we're not brought up
that way it takes about 18 months to get
used to because there's these subliminal
reactions now maybe this is
related to the pain button app maybe not
but could you describe the function of
the pain button app and and why that was
created yum it's like I said pain plus
reflection equals progress
whatever your form of pain the best
thing to do is to record it so this app
the way it works is as your experience
psychological pain you just quickly log
it you don't analyze it at the time but
you capture it what was it about or who
was with and what happened exactly the
nature of psychological pain is that it
passes fairly quickly the amygdala is
part of the brain is the part that's the
fight-or-flight part that gets
adrenaline and it reacts quickly and
then over a period of time whatever the
form of psychological pain it diminishes
and that's an opportunity to reflect and
because it's been captured in the app it
then can allow somebody to go back and
reflect on that and reflect on what you
should do about it when the next one
comes along and is it speak to the
person who caused you the pain is
whatever it might be and you write that
down and you record it and because it
keeps in a graphic way a presentation I
have graphs your pains the different
types of pains and the causes it gives
you sort of a biofeedback that allows
you to see if your actions are reducing
that pain and where the end that might
prompt you to change your actions or it
also shows whether you're following
through on your actions let's say you're
having a problem with the same person
doing the same thing causing your pain
but you're just bottling it up that then
if you choose to keep bottling it up
you're not going to resolve it it's just
gonna happen over and over again that'll
show up in the graph but if you do
something about it and you write it down
and you can analyze it and so it sort of
provides that kind of biofeedback that
allows people to make that progress and
a lot of people have told me
you know that it's better than a
psychologist because it's there well you
know every day of the week and and you
can see yourself how you're what's
causing your pain what sorts of pains
you have and it makes it an intellectual
exercise to come up with strategies to
do those things that stop causing you
those pains and get you what you want
for developing in addition to using this
type of logging tool whether it's the
app or if someone's carrying around a
small journal with them so that they
don't have Mis remember the details of
when they're triggered for instance are
there any tools that you have found
helpful for people in general employees
yourself and one that comes to mind
maybe you could you could chat about and
I'd love to hear about any others but is
transmetal meditation and I've read for
instance that you've said creativity
comes from open mindedness and
centeredness seeing things in a non
emotionally charged way could you talk
about TM and any other tools that you
have found to compliment
the pain button yeah so let me say the
tools in general we have developed a
whole bunch of tools that would be fun
to explain to you in all different ways
that are constantly being used and
they're just invaluable they're they're
great and I but I want to turn my
attention to Transcendental Meditation
which unlike let's say a adapt type tool
or some other kind of tool is a practice
that I've been doing for since 1969
whatever that is anyway a long time and
I think it's worth noting that
everything in our brain every emotion we
feel is physiological there are
chemicals that go through our brains
electronics that go through our brain
and they produce these impacts and
Transcendental Meditation is a practice
that takes one from a one's conscious
mind to us into almost a subconscious
state and allows one to relax and and
it's almost a blissful experience it
relieves all stress and it brings one
into the subconscious mind and through
brain scans they see that the amygdala
which is that fight-or-flight part of
the brain calms down actually and in
some cases they conjecture that it
physically changes and the prefrontal
cortex part of the brain which is kind
of that more thoughtful part lights up
and is enhanced and so that practice not
only creates an equanimity but by
bringing one into the subconscious part
of the brain it significantly enhances
the creativity it essentially opens a
passage from the subconscious to the
conscious so there can be a
reconciliation of those and and it's
really from the subconscious where
creativity comes from I mean if you
think about it
one doesn't go muscle creativity like I
doing a mathematical calculation or
something it's really like if you're
ultra relaxed maybe you take a hot
shower and these great ideas come to you
or you're sleeping and these things pop
up they come from your subconscious
pottery of your brain that where the
intuition and that comes from and so by
opening that passage essentially between
the subconscious part of the brain and
the conscious part of the brain it's
it's wonderful
it makes one more creative it makes one
kamar it makes one almost a little bit
like a ninja in a sense that everything
with that equanimity seems to be coming
at you in a more controlled centered way
so that you can react to it well and so
I found Transcendental Meditation to be
invaluable the specifics here of great
interest to me for a number of reasons
the first is that I practice a fan
a few different types of meditation but
I did a TM session this morning for
instance for 21 minutes because I find
it takes about a minute for me just to
stop fidgeting and get settled but when
do you typically do you do two sessions
a day when do you typically do your TM
give particular location any specifics
of that practice would be very great to
hear because their team has come up a
number of times that and I find it very
secular which appeals to me from people
like Rick Rubin legendary music producer
Chase Jarvis extremely accomplished
photographer and CEO what is what are
some of the details of your practice
well I think one of the things is don't
over worry about the details too much
just do it but the best way to do it is
you do it before breakfast and you do it
before dinner having not eaten much you
know we're not eating and and you do it
for the 20 minutes as you point out and
that you do it twice a day that's the
you know established practice I
basically do it let's say sort of two
thirds of the days and I would say I
probably maybe some days we'll do it
once and not twice but I also always do
it in addition whenever I have that
feeling of doing it as as a meditator
you probably know that you you can feel
the difference so as you're going
through the day you carry through almost
an ability to shift yourself from a
state of mind where there might be a
twinge of anxiety and then you can bring
yourself into that equanimity type of
state but you also I also find that
there's a time where I say I need to go
meditate and then I'll just meditate and
I'll meditate where I can when I can I
mean I prefer you know a quiet place
comfortable spot
I'm not rigid about the location but if
it was standing in my way my
circumstances were standing in my way I
would meditate on a plane
would meditate you know we're wherever I
could if it was a tree if it was noisy
then I was on a train I would still
meditate the meditation may not be as
deep it won't be as deep but it is so
good
it could be a noisy outside and I can
still go from one state to another not
the deep subconscious state but the
state of let's say tension to relaxation
so that's how I do it for those people
who aren't familiar with transmitted a
ssin it's thought of as mantra based
meditation so it's the repetition
typically characterized by the
repetition of a mantra or say a one or
two syllable sound that you do not say
out loud do you sit down and immediately
go into the repetition of the mantra or
do you take time to focus on your breath
or your bodily sensations before you go
into the mantra repetition I take a few
minutes to settle myself down just as
you're describing got it you know just
you know just as you're describing and
it feels good at that moment and then
you go enter it got it and you mentioned
before we delved into the TM other tools
that you and the people that bridgewater
have developed I'd love to hear you
describe any of those those tools are
like people carrying around an iPad with
them and whenever we go into meetings
there's a tool we call a doc collector
and it's a very easy tool to allow
people to express what they think is
going on and how people are doing and so
you know all meetings there's this data
that's collected that shows what
everybody's thinking while the meeting
is going on
now it's invaluable in many cases
because you're seeing what everybody's
thinking so it's so different and an
ordinary meeting it's silent largely I
mean
there's one person speaking at a time
and you don't know what the other people
are thinking in this particular case
what you do is all the time you see how
people are seeing things differently and
so what we do is we take that data as
it's happening and the computer does we
have a it programmed with algorithms
that will look at that data and will
then communicate back to them advice
because they just this computer behind
will then use that to know how they
think differently and by the way it's
enlightening you would have no idea how
differently people's brains are working
in a meeting or work in general the
things they pay attention to the ways
they interpret it are startling ly
different and they have the same kind of
patterns to them and so that discovery
allows people to know how they see
things different and appreciate how
other people things see things different
and then when they take that then that
allows them to know how to interact
better so the computer through this iPad
is doing processing in the background
and it will then also coach them in
other words when they're dealing with
somebody else or their it will provide
guidance it will provide feedback that's
continuous so it's a tremendous tool but
because you know what everybody's
thinking it's analyzing how everybody's
thinking provides that feedback and
gathers information across all of those
people and processes it by being able to
see relationships that no one person
sees so it's invaluable in an idea of
meritocracy we also use it for making
decisions we do something that we call
believability weighted decision-making
yeah if you got if you could elaborate
on that I'd love to to hear more about
it well you want to have an idea
meritocracy if you and I were partners
and we had a group of people and we were
partners
how are we going to decide on the best
things to do work I think we're gonna
want to idea meritocracy is when the
best ideas went out you have to have
rules for doing that you have to have
procedures so there are three things you
need to do the first is that you have to
put your honest thoughts on the table a
lot of people are hesitant to do that
they keep their honest thoughts back but
if you have a culture in which you can
put your honest thoughts on the table
and everybody does and that's the way it
operates now you see what people are
really thinking great that's a good
first step second step is you have to
have thoughtful disagreement you have to
know the art of thoughtful disagreement
so there are processes that we go
through in which people are really
hearing each other and as you go through
that process to make better decisions
than they could individually and then
the third thing is if disagreements
remain you have to have idea
meritocratic ways of getting past that
disagreement so how you going to do that
in it most places it's either autocratic
or democratic autocratic means the one
with the power makes the decision the
boss makes the decision Democratic is
one man one vote and it treats everybody
as though they're equally valuable so we
do what we call believability weighted
decision-making we have ways well let's
just imagine what it is before we get to
how we get to it
imagine you knew each person's
believability who's a better decision
maker at what so I'll use an example
that if you had a medical condition and
you went to doctors and you had a friend
well you would know your doctors better
than your friend and some doctors are
better than other doctors and so
consciously you're probably weighing
those decisions with consideration given
to their believed abilities in our place
we have ways of deter
people's believe abilities in many
different dimensions maybe if it's a an
accountant they would have greater
believability in accounting or maybe if
it's somebody who is more creative would
give them there are more points that
they actually get and they know that
that person's more creative and somebody
else might be more reliable and would
work well with the person who's creative
and so what we because of we have this
believed abilities according to all
those dimensions when we make a decision
we make a believability weighted
decision we literally on the iPad say
would you do this and then everybody
votes and it calculates what the vote is
on a believability weighted basis as
well as on an absolute basis and that
idea meritocracy not only produces
better decision-making but it also
produces a fairness that everybody
believes that the system is fair and
that is invaluable because when you have
disagreements or you even have
assessments which people are sensitive
to and you do that in a way that
everybody agrees are is fair that means
that they will go along with it more
that they the game is fair and and and
it's it you know works much better in
getting past disagreements so as I said
the third step is how do you get past
the disagreements if they remain and we
try to do that in an idea meritocratic
way through believability weighted
decision-making what are some of the
rules or guidelines that you have for
preventing disagreement from evolving
into highly emotionally charged fighting
in other words is it similar to say
nonviolent communication are there
specific rules that you think perhaps
listeners could also borrow that you
found to be very helpful for a
thoughtful disagreement you know there's
a whole series of protocols for example
there's a there's what we call the
two-minute rule
two minute rule means that if I say the
two minute rule
I'm allowed to speak for two minutes
without an interruption right and you
say the two minute rule you're allowed
to speak for two minutes without an
interruption there are protocols like
you repeat what the person is saying you
must repeat what the person is saying
and the points they're making so that it
demonstrates that you've taken in and
understand what their what they're
saying and then you repeat it we allow
disagreement to take place in different
formats it might rather than being in
person if somebody maybe is too
emotional in the moment or maybe they're
not good at thinking on their feet we
allow that disagreement to take place or
in a in a format that's essentially the
equivalent of the email exchanges in
other words if written format anyway
there are a bunch of those kinds of
procedures we have we agree they
mutually agree on who an arbiter is in
other words whenever there's a
disagreement that you can't seem to get
by as a standard practice the protocol
is to say let's find the person we can
agree who will be a moderator and help
us through that and because they
mutually agree on that person that then
the rules are fair and it's an easy
thing to do so there are many of those
tubs types of protocols that we use it's
also culturally like a big faux pas or a
big thing to lose your cool I mean in
that way you know I mean culturally okay
you know it's maybe you need a you know
a timeout so all those things enter into
it now those are very helpful and
actionable and I'd like to look at the
dynamics of making decisions as ace is a
solo opera
close to Scylla operator just as a
compliment or a contrast so if we flash
back to when you first began Bridgewater
associates so out of your two-bedroom
apartment at 26 years old do you recall
any of your first big wins or things
that you considered big wins at the time
and I'd love to just hear you describe
what went into what made those a big win
in other words the thinking behind it
you know the the funny thing is um I can
hardly ever remember my big wins I do
remember my big losses we talk we can
talk about those yeah it's so it's so
funny because you know I I look at it
and I said well I I guess I must have
had a bunch of wins or successes because
of you know how things have went you
know I the business is good and done
well and all of that but like I think of
my history and I really think of those
mistakes and I think that's so great
because it shows that that's a much
better learning tool but okay so my big
wins you know no I think about that at
that time I think no I the things I
remember with the were the fun things
but a guy you know guys I played rugby
with and parties and and those tons of
things I don't remember a particularly
big winning well I do remember some
things you know I remember one time when
we got the Kodak account mm-hmm again I
was you know in a position it's okay
here's a guy and he's analyzing the
markets and then he has a small team of
people that he's analyzing the markets
and so I didn't have a long track record
and I didn't have an institution and uh
you know sort of competing with the big
institutions of the world the JP
Morgan's and every
and and by the way we beat them well
anyway which shows that the individuals
the powers are within the individual but
anyway I remember when we got the Kodak
account because at the time Kodak was
you know a big important client and them
giving us that account was a big deal
for us because it was kind of a stamp of
institutional approval and it was all I
remember you know the money mattered too
because we would know that we were a bit
more financially secure so I remember
that as a big win and I remember it so
terrifically because we were asked to
submit research information and we were
just a small team of people and you know
we stayed up all night and with you know
pizza and beer and all of that and I
remember it so sweetly because it was
the dream of making our miracle happen
and we and pulling together
that's the meaningful relationships part
I believe that I want meaningful work
and meaningful relationships and so that
was what that was about and we got the
account and we won and that was a you
know that was a big deal why did you
guys win I think it's a combination of
being you know totally unconventional
and having better processes and then
there's a hell of a lot of determination
I think three things make up a
successful life by and large first you
have to have audacious goals big dreams
then when you are headed toward those
goals you're gonna have problems you're
gonna deal with reality you have to deal
with those problems in that reality
realistically learning from mistakes
writing down those principles on the
like so that's the second part dealing
with reality in a practical way where
you learn about mistake
and then the third is determination
because it if you're going for your
goals and you're encountering your
mistakes and you're learning
and you do that with determination
you're gonna get better all the time
you're good you can't help but get
better and you do that along in a amount
of time and you're going to far exceed
your dreams my success is far exceeded
what I ever imagined you know one bit at
a time and it's just that process if you
were to conversely look at intelligent
people who are unhappy what do you think
the primary causes of that unhappiness
are I think it goes back to this notion
of meaningful work of meaningful
relationships intelligence and Happiness
probably have no correlation with each
other in studies the it's repeatedly
been shown and money is very little
correlated with happiness the highest
correlation with happiness is community
am i part of a community do I feel
connections with other people that's
been you know literally genetically
programmed into us from it's estimated
between a million and two million years
ago before it was we were even mankind
so that sense of meaningful
relationships I think is very very
important and if you have meaningful
work like you're on a mission and you
have meaningful relationships and I
think it's almost impossible not to be
happy I mean they'll be unhappy moments
in your life that you encounter this
thing or that but the people who are
unhappy seem to be missing those things
I think this you know this might be a
good place to give listeners a little
bit of background that they probably
don't have which is a conversation you
and I had that I really appreciated when
I was very nervous at head not too long
ago doing a rehearsal of my talk
which explored some of my experiences
with manic depression and even a close
call with a near suicide in college and
you're very kind you came up and spoke
to me after I came off stage and I was I
was hoping perhaps you could talk about
some of what you shared with me and
perhaps your son's experience and what
he's found helpful in mitigating some of
these darker or harder moments that he's
also had sure I'd be happy to I should
stay say that when I described
unhappiness and answer to your prior
question before I was not dealing with
what also is clinical depression which
is also a different thing that's that's
it is a it is a chemical reaction having
to do with serotonin dopamine coming in
sports and sputters and so on there's a
physiological element that is driving it
and it's so that's that's a big thing so
my son when he was I I think about 27
filmmaker very creative was in his new
job in Los Angeles very excited stayed
up all night smoked marijuana partied
all night very energetic and and
basically went crazy he at the hotel he
took the computer that was at the
reception and smashed it he was he went
into the the police came he was
rebellious they beat him up and so and
so forth him and we then began our
journey through three years of his
bipolar episodes and that was
and you know incredibly difficult and
eye-opening and in retrospect wonderful
experience some of the most painful
experiences in retrospect give you the
appreciations that you wouldn't
otherwise have and that was that was
that experience and so ask your
questions pertaining to it I'd be happy
to tell you he made the quick answer to
this by the way is he did all the he did
things right eventually he did a lot of
wrong things in between but he came out
of that three-year period and he became
a successful film maker his movie that
first movie made was called touch with
fire which was love story with Katie
Holmes on bipolar and he has through
that movie in his speeches and so on
we know saved a number of lives and also
helped to really distinct is that
because those with bipolar are often
very creative people I learned that you
know genius creative genius is at the
edge of insanity
anyway what questions do you have about
that experience I'd love to hear what
what your son is found to be helpful in
terms of tools or resources approaches
routines anything that has that does
that he was found to help him better
navigate and manage everything that is
as part of his makeup I assess but as
much like it is part of my makeup sure
there's these really four protocols and
I gave him a Saint Christopher medal and
on the back I put the initials of those
four protocols so that he would keep it
close to him and so I know them well
first of all the first one is we said we
have to te-- and those are the initials
and we and that represented
take medicine and by the way the amount
of medicine that he's taken has because
of his improvements and so on has
diminished quite a lot to take medicine
and it also represented TM
Transcendental Meditation so do the
trent Transcendental Meditation and take
the medicine no drugs or substance abuse
non be clean go to bed
never too late it's not a matter of just
of eight hours sleep it's we have our
rhythms and that basically go to bed by
11:00 and maybe once a week you could be
up to a one o'clock in the morning and
then what we call monitoring now
monitoring is much less important to him
now but at the time his being open about
his bipolar and having people around him
know and actually sort of monitoring his
behavior so that they could raise a red
flag and help him deal with that if he
was going in one way or another that
that those were the things that were
very helpful in addition have to be very
careful about changing time zones so if
you're flying to you're up or far away
you have to do that in the way that you
pace it so that it doesn't get triggered
and as I said he went through this you
would never he's won now one of the most
centered people I know happily married
given us two grandkids you know it's
just been a miracle and I really do
believe it's that combination and and
he's learned and shown other people that
that combination could work for anybody
that's extremely helpful and I think
valuable for a lot of people listening
and I want to reiterate something that
you mentioned because I only realized
it's in the last maybe two years and
that is the going to bed earlier I've
always been very very nocturnal and a
night owl and particularly say on book
deadlines and so on going to bed at four
five
6:00 in the morning waking up very late
and that is that has historically
absolutely been correlated with a much
much more severe and extended down times
so I do just want to reiterate what you
said which is that going to bed by say
11 o'clock it has for me at least been
extremely helpful in in mitigating a lot
of what we're talking about by the way
it is so great that he is open and you
are open and you can communicate it
because I found out do you know that 24
percent of the population in one form or
another has been diagnosed with some
form of mental illness of some form of
challenge that because it you know the
brain is like a an organ it is an organ
and it has those things and some of the
most creative people you would know you
know that Abraham Lincoln and Winston
Churchill and Tchaikovsky on that the
list goes on and on of unbelievably
great brilliant creative people
simultaneously been challenged by this
and by making people aware and in one
dimension or another either whether they
are dealing with somebody who has such a
challenge or to D stigmatize it and
realize like I look at you what a role
model you are and by being open about
that particular challenge people can
really appreciate that like we have a
number of bipolar people who work here
and we and when you know how to deal
with it and there were you know
tremendous advantages to it too because
it's a it's a way of thinking yeah I
mean there's these mood chips but there
is also an unbelievably high percentage
of those people are creative so any in
certain professions and so on but anyway
I just want to
compliment you or express my
appreciation for you having this
conversation and and being so open with
it and it's I'm sure you would say as my
son would it's very helpful because when
everybody around you understands it it's
helpful to you too it is helpful and I
really appreciate the kind words
ray and I should also mention that for
decades I kept this secret and close to
the chest and I was very ashamed of just
the nature of how my physiology worked
ultimately and I was so fearful about
talking about a lot of this publicly in
even the TED talk was I had a very
separate very different TED talk that I
scrapped a few weeks beforehand because
I felt morally obligated to talk about
this more publicly and in doing so I
felt quite the opposite of what I feared
it was actually an enormous burden and
weight lifted off of my shoulders and
it's it's really been liberating to talk
more freely about it I understand that
completely because that's what that's
what my son does I mean that's my son's
reaction if you want to talk about it in
a you know in a more serious way I'm
quite an expert on the whole thing the
best doctors and you know I could I
really believe that I could probably be
of some help if you feel that it's not
entirely under control thank you
no I appreciate it and it's to segue a
bit here that so absolutely appreciate
the offer and that's that's something
I'll remember you seem like a very
astute cultivator of talent and what I'd
love to know is if there were any
particular mentors of your own who you
could describe or share with us that
could be very early on it could be in
your investing career but any any
mentors who come to mind and what what
they taught you or helped to cultivate
in you I remember nice
people not a mentor I couldn't go to a
mentor but I remember somebody who when
I was caddying and he was clerking on
the floor of the New York Stock Exchange
a very successful Wall Street guy and I
used to caddy for him and we would talk
about markets and he gave me not only
advice but there was the kindness and
the caring and the direction that was
helpful I'd I don't know that he was an
ongoing mentor but he was a role model
in many ways and did provide guidance so
maybe I think maybe he was but not an
ongoing mentor I remember teachers you
know that you know serve that role but
not much most of my learning has been
from mistakes I have a terrible rote
memory by the way I mean a terrible
anything that doesn't have a reason for
being what it is I practically can't
remember I can't remember phone numbers
you know names anything along those
lines so I tend to learn not by being
taught or going to my memory I learn
through my experiences and and my kind
of more subliminal learning well it
seems also that you're well-read and I'd
love to actually just go back for a
second to Einstein's mistakes when you
pick up a book like that it's two
questions number one how did you choose
that book or find it and number two is
how do you read what is your reading
process the book was given to me because
people know that I I like that stuff and
the way I read it depends on what I'm
reading but I will kind of skim and it
depends on how much time and and a lot
of things but generally speaking on I'll
try to go through a book pretty quickly
by being able to sort out what the main
ideas are from the digression so it is
kind of
a strategy you know how like they'll
tell you the story in the story and the
story might go on for a while and then
it then gets to the point they're trying
to make so I might when I'm going
through the stories I might go quicker I
might be scanning for the you know top
of the paragraph to get an idea what
they're doing doing and then go into the
section that I'm most interested I mean
I would say I would be typically
breeding that way unless it is something
in which you know there's a not that
sort of a book that there's either
something where on enjoying the the
flavor of the wording and the you know
the sentence structure and the beauty or
the the thoughtfulness and that I really
want to take that in and I don't want to
scan it'll vary I like to get the most
out of each book as quickly as I can
because the number that I'm trying to go
through it you know is comparatively
large so I've got a pile of books you
were sitting in front of me and you know
they torment me because they temp I'm
very curious I would say curiosity is a
big motivator from for mine so you know
the world has got much too much to offer
relative to my capacity to digest it
what are the books that you currently
have in front of you or that are sitting
sitting there like undone homework
assignments what do you would it what do
you currently have on the on the roster
or potential roster I have sapiens I
have the Greek hero Michael Lewis is the
undoing project the upside of inequality
the Serengeti rules from bacteria to
Bach and back which is about the
evolution of the mind a magic web I
don't know it's a whole pile over there
this is fantastic I do mostly original
research so in in addition to I mean
looking through books and going through
it like I really like to get into
you know the data I mean I'm on the
researcher basically what is there
anything that you're researching right
now or that you've researched recently
the bottom 60% of the population and
what the world in life in the economy is
like for them because there there are
two different economies in the world the
average is a very very misleading the
top two-tenths of one percent of the
population as a net worth which is about
equal to the bottom 90% combined and I'm
so I'm I'm researching more about what
that's like and it's it's quite a it's
quite a bleak difficult picture so
that's the thing I'm researching right
now what drove you to to research that
is it just to understand the
implications and secondary and tertiary
implications of that or is was there
something driving that we I think I
think right now we're in the midst of an
era that's very much like the 30s that
is in which this wealth and opportunity
gap and the populism that is being
that's coming from it and the divisions
which are great I mean large is a is a
defining moment of our time and this
exists around the world if economies
were to go down now I do believe that
there would be a great deal of conflict
and I think that we're seeing the
conflict play out politically not only
in the United States but you're seeing
it in different places or interactions I
think it's the it's the defining issue
of maybe that's overreaching but it is
certainly one of the most important
issues of our time and I mean this year
next year the year following because
that's the basis at which are we going
to have conflict or where one side is
fighting the other side this is a matter
of principles we're talking about
principles again are the principles that
hold us together as Americans greater
than those that divide us how are we
going to how are we going to be with
each other so this is there's this
understanding and and all of these
perspectives I think is is very
important at the time so I am definitely
going to come back to a related thread
on that but before I get there I wanted
to ask you of of the books that you
mentioned that you were not gifted how
did you or why did you choose any of
them like the Greek hero the undoing
project sapiens from bacteria to Bach
and back any of those why did you choose
them I would suppose that there each one
is different because of the themes of
interest I'm fascinated by evolution I
think evolution is the greatest force in
the universe and everything the purpose
of everything is to evolve we as
individuals are just vessels for our DNA
is evolving so i'm fascinated in
evolution i'm fascinated and how the
brain works the greek hero is very very
very interested in in terms of one of
the greatest books is Joseph Campbell's
hero of a Thousand Faces which takes the
character of you know going through life
and what are the attributes the
different people have some difference in
values so there it's an eclectic group
of interests I'm interested in nature a
lot so I tend to I'm also particularly
interested in the ocean so I will read
about nature in the ocean these are just
curiosities but they've become themes I
guess I'm not interested in cooking I'm
not interested in like a whole bunch of
things but so they are they do come in
these categories are there any
particular books that you could mention
and don't worry I won't be leave
the book stuff forever but any books you
mentioned Joseph Campbell that have had
a strong impact on your life or your
thinking and maybe a way to frame that
would be if you were and certainly one
of the books in answer to the question
that I'm about to pose could be your own
certainly but if you were to give say
every graduating senior in college or
high school a handful of books what
might you give them the books I give
them would be lessons from history this
is the Durant's they were the great
maybe the greatest historians of all
time anyway wrote 5000 years of history
probably wrote 5000 pages on it and they
took this book I think it's a hundred
and four pages and they took the themes
of history or it could be from religion
natural resources who knows each one of
these things and they looked at it for
themes of history through history I
think that that would be great river
from Eden by Dawkins Richard Dawkins
another very short book on evolution it
just really you know puts things in
perspective again I would say Joseph
Campbell's hero of a thousand faces
those would be the you know three books
that I would say that would be the
combination and the beauty of you know
particularly two of those books is it's
not going to take long to to read them
here over a thousand faces a little bit
dense but it's so rich so it's it's it's
a good one
why is it those are I need to get on
combine this as soon as we get off the
the phone but I why is it and maybe this
isn't true across the board but whether
it's in early stage startups or in the
realm of say broadly speaking hedge fund
or each structures or asset management
the best investors that I've met all
almost all have a fascination with
evolution why is that don't have a clue
we don't have to dwell on it for
whatever reason yeah it seems to be a
pattern up there their few Maxim's I'd
like to ask you about and if these are
miss quotes please correct me the first
is ask yourself whether you have earned
the right to have an opinion can you
elaborate on that I mean yeah I mean all
you want is the right answer right and
there's such a bias to think that just
because you have an opinion that it's
valuable or the thing is so stuck with
it I mean that's really stupid
mm-hmm and right I mean it's like if in
everything you just want the right
opinion wherever it's going to come from
so if you gain humility I believe that
one of the greatest tragedies of mankind
individuals is to hold wrong opinions in
their head that so easily could be
stress tested to find out if they're
right or wrong if you if you can sort of
give that up and think how do I know I'm
right you're going to significantly
raise the best raise your probabilities
of making better decisions I mean that
that's the that's the big thing the only
two things you need to do in the life in
order to be successful you first you
need to know what the best decisions are
and second you have to have the courage
to make them to do what's necessary and
on the first the greatest problem is
that people just look inside their heads
with for their opinions where they can
really get rid of little bit bad ones
and take the best that they can get
elsewhere and by doing that
by exploring different people's views
not just their conclusions but the
reasoning behind their conclusions they
can learn such a tremendous amount we
talk about books well the conversations
are much better than books so you can
have those conversations and learn when
people have differences and just pick
the best opinions right isn't that
sensible yeah no it's definitely
sensible how do you what are some good
questions that someone can ask to
explore someone's reasoning behind their
conclusions because I think that doing
it's so easy for people to become
charged are there any good questions for
those people who the vast majority are
not going to operate within say
Bridgewater associates what are what are
some good ways to explore
normally investigates someone else's
reasoning behind their conclusions well
I think the real driver of it is when
there's a difference of opinions to it
do you have a real curiosity to
understand why I mean it's it's really
through the you know the fear of being
wrong
combined with the curiosity of wondering
why somebody would have another opinion
and and that becomes the motivator and
so you you know you kind of ask why and
you think does that make sense
and then come back with other questions
so it's I would say I think most people
are you know too often they start with
opinion there's psychological tests that
show that people start with an opinion
and filter information that comes to
them to be consistent with their opinion
right yeah well then you're not living
in reality you're living in a sort of
illusion of confirmation bias right
right and it's it's so besides being so
damaging it's so what much less
enriching so this I think is related in
a sense to maybe another maxim that I'd
love for you to elaborate on which is
don't pick your battles fight them all
what does that mean that's one of the
most misunderstood so I'm glad you asked
Amanda because it's clear that many
things are symptomatic little things are
symptomatic of a bigger things so under
that principle it explains like if
somebody's behaving in a certain way and
you think well that's not a big thing
but you don't understand why somebody
would do that it may be symptomatic of a
bigger thing so when you start to you
know there's almost I might say pull
every thread as you start to pull the
threads you start to see
the connections because you're chilling
to get it what's everything symptomatic
of so that's what you're really trying
to get is it is that what is the person
like what is that situation like why
would it manifest itself that way so
it's a it's a it's a probably a
principle that I you know throws people
off and I probably haven't articulated
very well what are some of the biggest
challenges that you've had with in
Bridgewater at different phases of its
development I mean are there any were
there any particular sort of a Forks in
the road that are memorable to you where
you had to improve or fix something I'd
like to start with the overarching
challenge that is a constant challenge
and then we can go back to some of the
actuals you know that various Forks in
the road the overarching challenge is
people's - them's in other words they
think about in this this way there are
two use inside you there is the
thoughtful you prefrontal cortex type of
you know thoughtful you and then there's
the subliminal emotional you and you're
not aware actually of the subliminal
emotional you that's why it was Freud's
great the CICC of rien that there's the
subliminal that's really controlling you
but you're not in your consciousness and
there are those to use and they're often
at odds the example the classic example
would be of course something where you
did something that you didn't want to do
you ate the cake that you didn't want to
eat but you know anyway where you punch
somebody or something and so there are
these to use that are in a battle for
each other and so what we've observed on
a constant basis is that in addition to
having disagreements between people we
see that that emotional
subliminal them often can be in control
of their more thoughtful them and that
those are ongoing battles and that's
basically the battle that's the battle
that almost everybody all the time is
doing was so imagine how confusing it is
you know you have to use within you that
are battling with each other and then
you that somebody else you're dealing
with has to within them and so it could
get you know you get kids difficult you
know every every conversation at least
for people applause so that's it and if
you can if you could know how to deal
with that that's a constant struggle so
the thing that we find is that very very
very few people have a problem
intellectually liking what's going on
here it's fair it's honest there's no
politics it's anybody can in an idea
meritocratic way it can argue their case
there's no it's non-hierarchical it's
fantastic in all of those ways the
challenges that they have or then with
their emotional you reconciling with
their intellectual you and that's an
ongoing challenge you know that's all
all the time so that's it that's a theme
I would say is a you know a constant
thing okay well then you know twists and
turns at every phase in life you you
have you have different challenges I
mean you know not having any money any
resources and then having to do things
from from myself you know you're an
entrepreneur nope no money no resources
and not having to do sit by the computer
rent the place do all of that was one
kind of challenge and you know then you
have the small team and you have those
dreams and you work with them and it's
fantastic but you didn't have enough
resources and then
you grow and you have the exact opposite
things happening to you and they produce
their own challenges and you know you
have too many people and you don't get
to know each other as well as you did
before but you have plenty of resources
but you you know might have the you know
the challenge of how do you maintain
that quality relationship with that
larger group of people and then one has
to figure out how you main connect we
have 1,500 people at work at Bridgewater
how does that connectivity that same
kind of excitement and mission and
togetherness that happened when we had
five or fifty how is how is that
maintained and what that's a new
strategy so you always one always has
these different problems and and the
various inflection points that lead one
the forks and the road that are the
points that you're referring to and
they're the junctures you're referring
to lit the you're referring to so I mean
they're just so so many of them but I'd
look to maybe dig into is a a word think
that it's it's used a lot and then let
love to hear how you define and think
about risk specifically and I have a
quote here that maybe we could use as a
jumping-off point and I'm not sure
exactly where it's from but risky things
are not in themselves risky if you
understand them and control them if you
do it randomly and you're sloppy about
it it can be very risky and then it goes
on their words not yours the key to
success their words is quote figuring
out where is the edge and how do I stay
the right distance from the edge how do
you think about risk because that's a
word that a lot of people throw around I
have a feeling that that you think about
it it may be a more specific terms or
more clearly than a lot of folks how do
you think about or define risk well I
think the most important thing is
there's the
the risk of the ruin risk of being
knocked out of the game risk of the
unacceptable and then there's risk of
the painful mistake and they're a world
of difference like I have to know how
not to die
how not how to get knocked out of the
game that's an important risk so
thinking about all the different ways
that that can happen and making sure all
of those ways are covered is is number
one and then there's the other kind of
risk which is take it have the
experiences I guess maybe the example
would be if I was saying skiing comes to
mind you know you know don't kill
yourself but if you're not falling a lot
and hurting yourself a lot you're
probably not learning so to distinguish
between when you say risk-averse be very
risk prone in terms of being able to
have the experiences that are the
learning risky experiences that even
produce some of the pains that allow the
learning but you know don't get knocked
out of the game
and then I think of risk as you know how
do you do that how do i improve my
return to risk ratio and I know that the
most important way that you can do that
there's a few ways but one of the most
important ways is knowing how to
diversify one's bets without reducing
one's returns there are a bunch of
things that are equally good and you
know how to take all those equally good
things but they're not correlated would
mean that I could do a much better job
just to give you an idea I think think
of something as being correlated like
something like some abet something is
way we think of that as correlation but
you could almost think of it it has you
know a different kind of debt if it is
60% correlated
um and you start with a particular level
of risk and you add in the second and
third and fourth and fifth and a
thousand different items to diversify
yourself you will only reduce your risk
by about fifteen percent maybe a little
bit more than fifteen percent if they're
correlated if you do that with
uncorrelated things uncorrelated bets
[Music]
you at fifteen uncorrelated bets you
will reduce your risk by over 80 percent
so now the holy grail of investing the
thing that I learned and it's the most
important is that if I can have ten or
fifteen ideally fifteen but even if it's
five good uncorrelated bets that's
that's the holy grail so the holy grail
is 15 good uncorrelated bets because it
will if they're all equally good an
expected return in other words let's say
they were all going to have expect a
return of 10% by way of example then on
average you would do you won't lower
your expected return because they're all
on average about ten percent but in
terms of the risk you will eliminate
eighty percent of the risk so you
improve your return to risk ratio by a
factor of five so what I'm saying is
that knowing the value of uncorrelated
bets is incredibly important so when
you're thinking about it as a business I
think about it as a makes it basically a
betting strategy and every one of the
bets that I make but if you're thinking
about let's say your business is if you
can create good but uncorrelated thing
that power of diversification is so much
more valuable than trying to make anyone
bet much greater so I think about
diversification and I also think that in
terms of let's say bets raising my
probability of being right one of the
most important ways of raising my
probability of being right is not being
confident that I'm right and being able
to go out there and and gather the
triangulation so something for me is it
you know the technique is quality
triangulation basically you know if I
can find three people I don't know let's
say it's a medical condition but it
could be any decision if I can find
three people who are excellent experts
who will disagree with each other
because they're committed to the right
answer and I can get triangulation and
also listen to their disagreements
I'm significantly raising my
probabilities of of being right so there
are you know techniques like that
humility and triangulation of great
people is an excellent way of raising
ones probability of making a good
decision
so I'd lift it to UM peel the layers a
little bit on uncorrelated that's what
I'm wondering is so I think about this
just say in my own life with various
types of investing and I'm by no means
anyone with a track record like yours
but how the question that comes to mind
for me is or observation rather and I'd
love for you to smash it to pieces if
it's not accurate but that with a
limited data set you can if you're able
to crunch some numbers identify say
things that go up at the same time or
down at the same time so the correlation
or that are inversely correlated so when
a goes up B tends to go down
what point do you consider yourself
confident that something is uncorrelated
because it seems like you would need a
much larger data set to conclude
confidently that something is
uncorrelated well the I think there are
two ways of determining the correlation
uh that they're uncorrelated and that is
are they in you refer to the first but I
think it's the worst it still has value
which is how did they move together in
the past I think that's the the more
important is to understand like are they
intrinsically different things so you
know I if you were going to say I'm
going to invest in this Silicon Valley
startup and timber in Colorado or
something right you know that those are
intrinsically different things so and I
think you can get a good sense of that
by you know just even knowing what they
are so you'll know that that particular
startup will have a particular thing
that will make it successful I don't
know what we could imagine it might be
but it might be having nothing to do
with something else so now I think of
what are the fundamental determinants of
the price movement and you don't have to
get so precise about it I like to think
it through probably maybe an overly
analytical way but knowing that they're
intrinsically different is good enough
and then and then now back to the your
question of the data set it then becomes
a I'm gonna give you more complex answer
than you probably want but I love I love
complex let's do it okay so it has to it
has to do with a combination of sample
size and environmentally by biases
differences in other words first
how much sample size you have and is
that over many years or did they have
something in common that would affect
them so if I have many years and a large
number of samples in that number of
years I can have a higher level of
reliability if I'm just looking at the
numbers then if I had a short term
period because correlations will change
right so because it so is it a number of
years and is it in a different
environment I have a rule in terms of
most of my decision-making is it it has
to be timeless and universal so timeless
means if I take a period of time it were
the correlations or that which I'm
discovering true in all of those periods
of time so I like to go back a long time
but let's say you have a limited amount
of data that's a handicap the more data
you have the better but still if I
change the periods in this year did that
correlation was it the same as the
correlation in the prior year and was
the correlation the same in the year
before that the correlation let's say of
daily returns or you could have
correlation a minute returns so so
timeless and as far back as you go and I
like to deal with universal what I mean
by universal is that if if I have a
decision rule or equities or bonds or an
asset class or something and I see its
behavior did it behave the same in with
the same drivers in another country and
another country so were the correlations
for example between stocks and bonds in
Spain similar to the correlations
between stocks and bonds
Brazil similar to this correlation
between stocks and bonds in the United
States okay that'll give you more of a
sense that the correlation between
stocks and bonds is X then if you have
just it happening in one place so
timeless and universal are just for most
decisions are rules that I look at but
at the end of the day I get really more
comfort by being able to understand the
intrinsic determinants so if I'm talking
about investments because that's the
subject we can talk about a lot of other
things but anyway if I'm talking about
correlations of investments every
investment is a lump sum cash payment
now for an income stream in the future
if I buy a bond I give a lump sum
payment and they're gonna give me so
much per month all the way for whatever
the length of the bond is the maturity
over the 20 years or whatever that is if
I'm having a stock it's a lump sum
payment and then we estimate what are
the future cash flows so this is
uncertainty about those cash flows but
that but you will look at those cash
flows they will all be affected by the
discount rate the interest rate we use
to calculate the present value so there
will be an intrinsic reason that they
will be correlated and there will be
intrinsic reasons that they that drive
their correlation let's say if I'm
getting too technical please excuse me
but all of those investments are going
to have the interest rate that we're
using to calculate the present value in
common and therefore that will drive a
correlation between that while the items
that affect their cash flows could be
different and that will drive then
something that one can analyze and see
that there
correlations would be different from
that attribute if you brake investments
down and you look at what the causality
is it's you know it's it's better than
if you're just looking at past numbers
but you could look at it either of those
two ways ideally both for those people
who would like to get a better
understanding of the some of the
underlying factors that affect the
economic engine so to speak interest
rate etc what would your recommendation
be if they wanted to educate themselves
I did a 30 minute video called how the
economic machine works in which
everything that I know that it's the
most value describes in 30 minutes it's
on YouTube I'd recommend that they go
there in 30 minutes
they'll have most of what I think is
valuable in how and in understanding how
it works perfect
it's a pretty simple machine it's like
almost anything if you if you think
about it most of the important things
that are driving almost anything can be
described pretty simply so that's what I
attempted to do in that video on YouTube
great it's um it's been downloaded 5
million times and any people it's rated
highly so I think it I think I think
it's helpful and I will everybody
listening I'll link to that in the show
notes as well so people can easily
access that just to pose a hypothetical
because I'd love to hear how you
approach it not necessarily if it's a
long or short decision although it could
be but just to hear how you would even
go about assessing a potential
opportunity because for instance I'm
very primitive compared to how your
operation are you would approach
investing but living in Silicon Valley
for instance as long as I have 17 years
now I have an informational advantage
when it comes to choosing and assessing
different startup opportunities and
elsewhere people might have a say
analytical or behavioral advantage er
blank if if you were to look at for
instance cryptocurrency Bitcoin all this
other stuff how would you even begin to
assess that and whether it poses a good
or bad opportunity for investment well
everything I look at is I tried to look
at who are the buyers and sellers and
what are they what motivates them and
what are they gonna do mm-hmm
so I break it down I analyze now I
wouldn't know I don't know how or do
that in Bitcoin and I don't know that it
would apply to everything but as a
general theme if you know who the buyers
and sellers are and what their
motivations are how big they are and so
on you can you know you can pretty much
calculate you can go a long way to
understanding what the price is likely
to do in the future that's very
different from something like value
investing which is something that says
you know am i lump sum payment today is
this and the future cash flows over the
next number of years will be this so I'm
very much much more driven to the buying
and selling in terms of something like a
cryptocurrency first of all I'm not an
expert on the crypto currencies I would
think that what I'm describing is super
important to get at because there are
two purposes of a currency any currency
is a medium of exchange or a store hold
of wealth when we think of dollars and
you may use it as a medium of exchange
or if we're holding it as a bond it's a
payment over a period of time and that's
it's a store hold of wealth in the case
of crypto currencies right now it's not
a very practical medium of exchange yet
I mean it you know I have bitcoins and I
try to go spend them and it's not easy
to go spend
and then when we think of it as a store
hold of wealth no today it's primarily a
speculative market so it's somebody
knowing it's not its intrinsic value
that you're going to be looking at it's
really thinking about who are the buyers
who are the sellers and what they are
likely to do and projecting that that's
going to be the driver of investing in a
cryptocurrency could you talk a little
bit more about assessing the motivations
of buyers and sellers and you could do
with any asset class or any kind of
hypothetical but specific example
because I guess in my mind as as someone
who's very much junior varsity with all
of this that the motivations would seem
to be at least if people are speculating
to get rich both on the selling side and
on the buying side so how do you dig
deeper than that and any examples would
be super helpful every buyer has
behavioral characteristics for certain
reasons and so if you if you say let's
say stocks to use a very simple example
a typical individual maybe mutual fund
buyer will buy after something's gone up
because they think it's a better
investment and they'll sell they'll get
scared when it goes down because they'll
get scared and they'll think it's a
worse investment whereas a typical
institutional investor or a pension fund
will buy when it goes down because they
have to rebalance their portfolio to
keep an asset allocation mix at a
certain level and so if they're losing
money in something and making something
another they will bail rebalance in a
mechanical way and so there are many
different ways of knowing of saying okay
who are the biggest ones who are the
littlest ones you know but most
importantly the biggest ones and what
are they motivated to do and by my
understanding and in that way you know
it's important so you you have a lot
a lot of different buyers and sellers in
different markets for different reasons
that when you examine it you know kind
of makes sense it
somebody might and you you be acquire
some stock man go public and then the
owners have a window that they or it's
closed for them to sell it right and
then the window opens up and then
they're going to sell at that time I'm
just giving you a whole bunch of
examples that one can know or attempt to
know that are more than just people
wanting to make money
somebody's squeezed you have you know
you have a financial squeeze and they
need cash so that they're motivated to
sell it because they need cash there are
lots of different reasons right meaning
I can just a distress seller in the last
case right and to know on an ongoing
basis that the market is made up of that
mixture mm-hmm and so you know as much
as as much as one can it is a good way
of of getting a sense of that very
common where I'm sitting right now I'm
in San Francisco and so I've read and I
please correct me if I'm wrong but from
Tony Robbins
book which included you that I suppose
over a long enough period of time
anyone's favorite asset class I'm
paraphrasing this but will decrease by
fifty to seventy percent or something
like that yeah that's what I said okay
got it so what are the implications the
the most important implications of that
from the behavioral standpoint of
investors like what how should that
change their thinking or behavior well
it goes back to the point I was making
before that you can come up with a bunch
of equally good investments I mean
generally speaking all investments are
competing and what that means is if one
was clearly better than another more
money would go into it bid up its price
and then it would be comparably
according to the marketplace
the marketplace is pretty smart yeah not
to be successful and being tactical
you have to be better better than the
marketplace and that isn't easy
therefore the marketplace is pretty
smart that all of those assets are going
to have roughly speaking comparable
expected returns other than the
surprises that will take place in the
future and you have a choice you're
either going to be smart enough that you
think you're gonna bet against somebody
else that they're gonna go up or down or
you're going to diversify so you can
take these assets and achieve a level of
balance with those assets that doesn't
cost you in expected return but provides
you a much lower level of risk and if
you can reduce your risk and keep your
expected return the same you got to do
that so diversification as we were
talking about before can allow an
individual I explained in that book I
thought by the way it's a great book
because what Tony did was to take
concepts and and make them very clearly
conveyed for the average reader I
explained he interviewed me in the book
how to achieve that kind of balance so
that you're not going to have that
because if you lose 50 or 75 percent of
your money enough in a decline let's say
50 percent that means you need a hundred
percent return to get back right where
you started yeah so you you can't you
can't allow yourself to do that that's
the risk of ruin thing so
diversification proper diversification
can reduce your risk without reducing
your return there are many different
ways to diversify how would your
approach differ most if it does from say
a David Swensen my approaches I was
describing it is to balance the risks
based on the two factors that we were
the two determinant so we
about before how are what are the
intrinsic drivers of those and then also
what are the timeless and universal
correlations of those assets and to it
to achieve balance I'm always looking
for a value-added risk-reducing trait
the issue is to look at the intrinsic
characteristics and and and and achieve
and achieve balance where
diversification can get very tricky in
the world of say startup investing you
mentioned in brief this lockup period is
where someone I'm a perfect example of
this has made investments that are
illiquid for a period of God knows how
long 7 to 12 years in some cases and
what started off as a plan to have say
ten percent of one's liquid net worth
invested into startups suddenly becomes
80 percent of the pie chart I think
Michale it if you have an eighty percent
of your portfolio concentrated portfolio
and in the one particular asset that's
right I would urge you to find out how
you're gonna hedge that thing yeah and
you know that there are different ways
that you can make that hedge you know to
some extent it's by something but but to
some extent you might go into a contract
you you know it could be done almost I
don't know the nature of the particular
types of investments but it's if it's a
particular company with a particular
profile that'll be unique to it the only
way that you're gonna be able to hedge
that is to go into some probably
investment bank and actually explain to
them their circumstances and find out
you know a structure that is that they
might be able to come across it's going
to be a highly impure hedge and you know
it needs to be engineered so it you know
it's a very difficult thing and because
80% of your net worth is tied up you
can't go
have the cash go buy something that's
going to balance it and you wouldn't
want to borrow and then borrow the cash
to buy something different because
probably it's correlation with whatever
you're using as a diversifier is not
gonna be reliable and so you're you know
you could really get screwed so I don't
know that I have a good answer for that
yeah it's it's a tough one because like
you said looking because I don't have
anywhere close to the cash required to
say take a sort of derivative position
to try to hedge it's it's very
challenging and like you also observed
the sort of impure nature of trying to
do any kind of secondary with a
forward-looking promissory note or
something like that in any case I don't
know more people to tears but it's a
very common problem in in Silicon Valley
it's difficult because it's it's also a
liquid you know so much money is a
liquid so people can would be real rich
on paper but pretty poor cash wise I
mentioned tactical and psychological so
in a situation like this where you can't
there is no magic answer there is no
necessarily non-obvious solution to this
it's just a tough position to be in
where you stand to potentially lose a
lot what do you say to yourself what's
your self-talk in a situation like that
where you may just be stuck in a
position where they you can't get out of
a from a from an investing perspective
well I think of like how bad am I gonna
get hurt kind of thing and I almost
think in portfolios sometimes that it's
better to take a portfolio and you have
a certain amount of cash and you think
how bad am I gonna get and then you
could take your risk and put it in
another portfolio and separate the
portfolios rather than to blend them
together so that you're you know you're
actually thinking okay how bad is it
gonna get and and also like okay so it's
the nature of the beast
and what's the big deal I mean you're
gonna you know when it comes down to it
you're gonna have a you know what can
they take away from you
right so that you're gonna have a you're
gonna have a bed to sleep and you're
going to have food you're gonna have you
know friends the most basic good things
you're playing the game and it's the
nature of the beast so I guess that's
like for me if you know it's like I keep
thinking what are they gonna take away
from me what's it really going to mean
have you ever I've read for instance
there's a book titled more money than
God which I read a few years ago and
there were a number of cases in that
book of very over the long-term
successful investors who had hit a point
of overwhelm or such high levels of
stress that they did based on my
recollection she could be faulty but
effectively hit the reset button they
liquidated all their positions and kind
of started over is that something you've
ever done and if so how did you think
about that no I've never done it because
of stress I've I've liquidated positions
to take risk off the table because
certain things have happened and I'd say
listen I just don't know and I'd rather
now take risk off the the table but I do
know of one terrific investor who got
into a very bad mindset I mean he just
couldn't make anything work for a period
of time and that started to affect his
psychology that worsened his
decision-making and what he did was he
brought his positions down to such a
small level that he was continuing to
play the game but he but with amounts
that wouldn't have that psychological
effects until he could get back into
that mindset and get back into the
groove did that work for him and all
that work for him psychology is a big
deal psychology is a big deal in the
markets that's why I also find that my
rule day style
I'm trading a rural meaning I take a
rule and decision rule so it's not a
it's not it's it's just an the algorithm
is just an expression of my criteria and
then I put it into an algorithm but by
knowing how that algorithm works and
having it operate next to me in other
words I'm doing my decision making in my
way and then all my thinking is
programmed into the computer so that
there is a parallel decision-making
going on by the computer has been
fabulous because that computer ain't got
no emotions and it's just like you know
I don't know a computer chess game and
you know and it and it's great and it's
been a fabulous experience to have me
and it playing the game together so -
taking the emotions out of it is a real
real plus and I'm a meditator so I can
you know I would say you know I don't
get as emotional as some people do and
but but when you go through it because
you go through a process in which you're
thinking I say something's going against
you and of course trades will always go
against you you it's not like you buy
something and from that point forward it
goes up that you then sell it and you
know I mean there's it's not like that
and so if you buy something that's good
value it might go down before it goes up
and then when you're and you're when
you're wrestling with okay now do I sell
it it's not like that's the moment
either so all every moment you don't
know whether you're are you missing
something or are you wrong or is it just
too early all of that psychology enters
into it and you start to think about
multiple possibilities and and then you
know okay there's more opportunity
that's why the
strategies I'm describing the
combination of diversification so no one
that dad is gonna matter so much so I
have the casino of bets so yeah if I'm
wrong on on one or here it's okay but
that casino means all my games on
balance are going to play pay off and
and and then that that notion of
systemizing the decision rules these
things have been very helpful to me and
I think this is a great place to to wrap
up and I think it's it's I'm just gonna
read a small piece from your book which
I highly recommend everybody check out I
mean just to give everybody an idea one
of the testimonials blurbs on the book
is from Bill Gates quote Ray Dalio has
provided me with invaluable guidance and
insights that are now available to you
in principles so if I think that this is
going to do a lot of good in the world
and help people to make better decisions
and here's a quick quote some quote
every day each of us is faced with a
blizzard of situations we must respond
to without principles we would be forced
to react to all things life throws at us
individually as if we were experiencing
each of them for the first time if
instead we classify these situations it
types and have good principles for
dealing with them we will make better
decisions more quickly and have better
lives as a result and I I'm very excited
to see what this book does in the world
and I suppose just as is one of the very
last questions why did you why why did
you decide to put this book out why now
I'm at a stage in my life where my
objective is no longer to be more
successful myself I'm in a transition
sixty eight years old and I felt that my
number one goal is to help people be
successful without me
and having this collection of recipes
that it's been built up over that period
of time and passing it along so that
basically everything that I know is a
value in the book
frees me of that responsibility and as
what I you know feel as a sense of
responsibility and I hope everybody I
wish everybody would do the same like
I'd love to know you know how many
people's principles would you love to
know I by the way I've been speaking to
a number of I don't use the names but a
number of very successful people and I
know now that they are going to be more
inclined to put their recipes out and I
think it'll be fabulous you should write
your principles as you do chair your
principles in many ways but as they're
as those those recipes and you give
these recipe books and people then can
compare one to another and debate them
and operating at that principle level I
think is a responsibility that I have to
do and it kind of frees me up to go to
my next stage of life well I've been
taking notes throughout this entire
conversation I'm going to simulate my
own pain button and have a number of of
homework assignments that I'm looking
forward to tackling and for people
listening they can certainly learn a lot
about the book and dig in principles
calm they can find you on Twitter and
elsewhere at Ray Dalio is there anything
else you would like to suggest or ask or
encourage people to do before we wrap
this up I'll just have their own
principles that they believe in be open
minded right their principles down
compare them with others find out be
guided by principles be a principled
person I would say that those things
probably will help them be not only more
successful but you know comfortable with
themselves
perfect well rate I really appreciate
all the time this has been a lot of fun
for me and I've been looking forward to
this ever since we we met and you're so
kind after
bolstering my confidence after my
rehearsal at Ted so I really appreciate
all of it and the work that you do you
nailed it it was great we were both like
the same we're both nervous that we were
going to do a lousy job and we both got
through it well so anyway thank you also
for your very interesting questions and
the wonderful exchange thank you my
pleasure entirely and for everyone
listening links to the book to raise a
video explaining the economy everything
that we talked about can be found in the
show notes I will link to everything at
tim dot blog forward slash podcast where
you can find the show notes for this
episode and every other and until next
time thank you for listening hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday the vet provides a little morsel
of fun before the weekend and five
bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens I get asked all the time
if you could only use one supplement
what would it be
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it in the 4-hour
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it too boy getting sick I
take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day as listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show you can receive 30% off of
your first order by visiting athletic
greens comm forward slash Tim that is a
great deal on one of my favorite
products and it covers my basis each day
it is part of my routine and it leaves
you less to worry about if for instance
I have to skip a meal or just can't get
high quality meal so check it out go to
athletic greens dot-com forward slash
Tim and learn all about this episode is
brought to you by 4 Sigma Dec founded by
the genius Finn's who lit the internet
on fire and you may have heard of their
mushroom coffee which features chaga and
lion's mane which has taken Silicon
Valley by storm I use it pretty much
every day either that or the chaga
which is decaf a separate version and I
use both of these primarily for focus
and productivity they just get you going
let you up like a Christmas tree
so definitely check it out people are
always asking me what I use for
cognitive enhancement and for right now
this is the answer I try to force this
on all of my houseguests it is a hell of
a thing if I have employees or people
come over who are working on projects
with me I always try to feed it to them
because I'm going to get the limitless
effect it's a lot more out of them the
first time I mentioned this product and
for sig Matic on the podcast your
products sold out in less than a week so
you may want to check them out soon if
you're listening to this and the coffee
tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you would get in a
regular cup of coffee I don't get any
jitters acid reflux or any stomach burn
any of that it's very unusual and very
very cool so if you don't like caffeine
they also offer very strong but caffeine
free mushroom elixirs which I will
sometimes have in the evening I find
chaga specifically to be very very
grounding and earthy so that is another
option and I have a cupboard full of
there
products at the moment which is right
around the corner my kitchen you can try
something you can try a sample pack
which is great also right now by going
to four sig Matic calm or - Tim that's
four sig Matic fo you are SI g ma TI c
calm forward / Tim and use the code Tim
TI m to get 20% off of your first order
and they're not that expensive anyway if
you are in the experimental mindset I do
not think you'll be disappointed
so try them
[Music]
[Applause]